ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
ARAMBULA.
BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BURNER* BATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES CHAU
[inaudible]
CHEN [inaudible]
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU [inaudible]
COOLEY COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
DALLY.
DAILY DEEP. EIGHT MEN FLORA
[inaudible]
FONG.
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN.
GABRIEL [inaudible]
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ AS GRAY.
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE.
LIMóN OWN [inaudible]
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY.
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI.
NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK
QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS RAY IS US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH
[inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
TEEN VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON WEBER WICKS.
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN THE REVEREND PATTY
OSHITA REVEREND OSHITA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
ALL OF HUMANITY IN ALL LIFE ARE
NOT SEPARATE FROM THE
ENVIRONMENT OF OUR ONE PLANET
EARTH.
WE KNOW THIS.
IN OUR MINDS WE KNOW THIS TO BE
UNDENIABLY TRUE.
FROM THE EARLY NINETEEN SIXTIES
THE ORIGINAL ASTRONAUTS FROM
MERCURY.
SEVEN OFTEN THOUGHT TRANSFORM
WHEN THEY FIRST ALL THE EARTH
FROM SPACE.
THIS MOVING EXPERIENCE WAS FELT
FROM OUR VERY FIRST ASTRONAUTS.
TO THE INTERNATIONAL ASTRONAUTS
WHO HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SERVE ON THE SPACE STATION.
THE EXPERIENCE WAS OFTEN
DESCRIBED AS TRANSFORMING.
DR MARK SHOW HAMMER.
A JOHNS HOPKINS UNIVERSITY
MEDICAL PROFESSOR.
WHO SERVED AS THE CHIEF
SCIENTIST FOR HUMANE RESEARCH AT
NASA'S JOHNSON SPACE CENTER SAID?
YOU WILL HEAR THIS FROM
ASTRONAUTS NOT INFREQUENTLY.
THAT THEY HAVE FELT THE ONENESS
OF HUMANITY.
COLONEL CHRIS HADFIELD WHO
SERVED AS THE COMMANDER OF THE
INTERNATIONAL SPACE.
STATION.
OFTEN SHARE THE INCREDIBLE
EXPERIENCE.
OF SEEING THE EARTH FROM SPACE.
WHAT THIS EXPERIENCE?
HE CERTAINLY UNDERSTOOD THAT THE
ENTIRE WORLD.
WITH A SINGLE SYSTEM.
FROM SPACE HE COULD LITERALLY
SEE THE INTERCONNECTEDNESS OF
ALL LIFE.
ASTRONAUT RUSSELL SHE CART FROM
THE POLLEN NINE MISSION.
IN SHARING HIS EXPERIENCE OF
SEEING THE EARTH AS THE OR
PRINTED SAID.
THE WHOLE PROCESS OF WHAT IT IS
YOU IDENTIFY WITH BEGINS TO
SHIFT.
YOU BEGIN TO RECOGNIZE THE YOUR
IDENTITY IS WHAT THE WHOLE THING
THE WHOLE PLANET.
YOU LOOK DOWN THERE AND YOU CAN
IMAGINE HOW MANY BORDERS AND
BOUNDARIES YOU CROSS.
AND YOU DON'T EVEN SEE THEM.
THERE YOU ARE LOOKING DOWN FOR
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE ARE KILLING
EACH OTHER OVER IMAGINARY LINE
THEY YOU.
NOT EVEN AWARE OF YOU CAN'T SEE.
WHAT'S THE MANY ASTRONAUTS HAVE
SEEN AND FELT WE KNOW IS TRUE.
THERE WITH THEM I'D HAVE OPEN.
AND THEY KNOW THAT WE MUST CARE
FOR THE LIFE GIVING ENVIRONMENT.
OF OUR ONE PLANET EARTH.
IN THAT OUR SHARED HUMAN
EXPERIENCE HAS NO BORDERS.
NOW MORE ME NOW TO WITH KINDNESS
AND GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
WOMAN AGUIAR-CURRY AS SHE LEADS
US IN THE PLEDGE.
IS AGUIAR-CURRY.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF AND WHICH IS AN ISRAEL
[inaudible] FOR ALL.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
WEDNESDAY JANUARY NINTH TWENTY
NINETEEN THE ASSEMBLY MET AT
SEVEN AM ON WILL STEVEN CHOI
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SIXTIETH
DISTRICT PRESIDING CHEAPER
DEDUCTIBLES.
TERROR CALDERON MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS.
THAT THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
RESIDENT HAITIANS IN PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE.
NINE MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY. FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHIRLEY WEBER.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM
PATTERSON AND FOR ILLNESS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BILL BRO
[inaudible]
HI.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN TO HAVE
GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE
FLOOR TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT.
FIVE AND ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN AGUIAR-CURRY LOW MOAN AND
SMITH TO SPEAK ON AND GERMAN IN
MEMORY TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS I WOULD ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS AT THIS
TIME.
MEMBERS WE HAVE LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS BEFORE THIS HOUSE.
WHAT WE ARE GOING TO MOVE AT
THIS TIME TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY AND I WOULD ASK MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
?
MEMBERS WE ARE ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION. TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
I'M GOING TO BE CALLING ON
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS IRWIN.
AS WELL AS TAKE YEAR CURRY.
SMITH.
IN THE MALL.
ON THIS SPECIAL GERMAN IN MEMORY.
I AM FIRST WHEN RECOGNIZE.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN JACQUI IRWIN FROM
MY DESK IN THE REAR CHAMBER MISS
OR WHEN THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY I ASK YOU TO JOIN US IN
REMEMBERING AND HONORING TWELVE
BEAUTIFUL SOULS.
WHO WERE TAKEN FROM US ON
NOVEMBER SEVENTH? TWENTY
EIGHTEEN IN THOUSAND OAKS.
THE SHOOTING A BORDERLINE WAS
SENSELESS UNIMAGINABLE AND UNTIL
THAT DAY SOMETHING WE THOUGHT
COULD ONLY HAPPEN ELSEWHERE.
WELL WE FEEL INDESCRIBABLE
SADNESS WE HAVE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO RISE ABOVE THIS
ATTEMPT. TO MAKE US FEEL FEAR.
INSTEAD OFFERING LOVE AND
SUPPORT TO ONE ANOTHER.
IT WAS A COLLEGE NIGHT OF
BORDERLINE HAD DECADES OLD HUB
WHERE OUR YOUNG PEOPLE.
INCLUDING MY CHILDREN ENJOYED
LIGHTING DANCING AND SOCIALIZING.
BORDERLINE WAS A PLACE TO
RECONNECT WHEN THEY CAME BACK
FROM SCHOOL OR TRAVEL.
A PLACE TO STAY IN TOUCH WITH
FRIENDS A PLACE THAT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN SAFE.
I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT EACH OF THOSE WHO WERE
TAKEN FROM US THAT NIGHT.
CODY GIFFORD KAUFMAN GRUPPEN
CAMERARIA.
HE WAS TWENTY TWO YEARS OLD
KNOWN TALL FOR IT'S EASY GOING
MANNER HIS SMILE AND HIS ENERGY.
IT WAS A TWENTY FIFTEEN GRADUATE
OF C#M HIGH.
HIS PASSION FROM A YOUNG AGE WAS
BASEBALL HE WAS A ROLE MODEL TO
YOUNG PEOPLE AS AN EMPIRE FOR
THE CAMERI --
BASEBALL LEAGUE.
HIS DREAM WAS TO SERVE HIS
COUNTRY IN THE US ARMY.
HERE'S SURVIVE LIES PERRANCE
JASON KAUFMAN SHALL GIVE OR TAKE.
HIS STEP PERRANCE FOUR BROTHERS
JOSH DOMINIC CHANDLER.
CHASE.
AND SISTERS LOGAN TATE AND ROAR
EARLY HIS GRANDPARENTS.
AND MANY LOVING RELATIVES.
MORE.
THAN. TWENTY YEARS OLD.
HE GREW UP IN CARPINTERIA DAYS
BEFORE HIS TWENTY FIRST BIRTHDAY.
MARK STUDIED PHOTOGRAPHY AT
SANTA BARBARA CITY COLLEGE AND
WORK SUCCESSFULLY.
IN THE SERVICE INDUSTRY WHERE HE
WAS RECOGNIZED FOR HIS STRONG
WORK ETHIC.
HE WAS KNOWN FOR HIS BIG SMILE.
GENIALITY AND DEDICATION TO HIS
FAMILY.
MARK WAS AN EMPLOYEE AT
BORDERLINE.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS FATHER
MARK MESA SENIOR.
HIS STEP MOTHER KELLY MARSH MESA.
HIS SISTER'S ID AND HANNAH AND
HIS BROTHER JAYLEN.
BIZARRE ONE THAT.
LIKE A MAN.
TWENTY ONE WAS A NATIVE OF
NEWBURY PARK AND INSPIRING
ELECTRICIANS.
JUST BEGINNING HIS CAREER.
HE GRADUATED FROM NEWBURY PARK
HIGH SCHOOL WHERE HE EXCELLED IN
SOCCER AND BASEBALL.
HIS MECHANICAL ABILITY LET HIM
TO THE SPORT OF OFF ROADING
WHICH HE ENJOYED WITH HIS FAMILY
AND FRIENDS.
BLAKE WAS KNOWN FOR GOING ABOVE
AND BEYOND FOR THOSE IN HIS LIFE.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS PARENTS
DAN AND LAURIE.
HIS BROTHER AIDEN GRANDPARENTS
AUNTS AND UNCLES COUSINS.
AND EXTENDED FAMILY.
JAKE DONNA AND JAKE WAS TWENTY
ONE AND GREW UP IN NEWBURY PARK.
HE OVERCAME MANY CHALLENGES IN
HIS LIFE BUT REMAINED FORWARD
LOOKING AN OPTIMISTIC.
HE WAS AN AVID CAPABLE MECHANIC
WITH A PASSION FOR EXTREME
SPORTS INCLUDING OFF ROADING.
JAKE INFLICTING THEM FOR BEST
DAMON WERE BEST FRIENDS HE IS
SURVIVED BY A LARGE FAMILY HIS
PARENTS KATHY AND CAN.
SISTER ALEXIS GRANDPA
GRANDPARENTS BILL JOE CHECK AND
VICTORIA AND MANY MANY COUSINS
AUNTS AND UNCLES.
MS SMITH YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
SHAWN ADLER AGE FORTY EIGHT WAS
A HARDWORKING ENTREPRENEUR.
WHOSE PASSION AND POSITIVITY
ENERGIZED EVERYONE AROUND HIM.
A RESIDENT OF SEAMY VALLEY HE%
RECENTLY OPENED RIVALRY ROASTERS
SERVING HIS CUSTOMERS COFFEE
WITH ORGANIC FAIR TRADE BEANS.
WHILE WORKING TO GROW THE COFFEE
SHOP SEAN WORKED AT BORDERLINE
BAR AND GRILL AS A SECURITY
GUARD.
JOHN IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
FRAN AND SONS DYLAN AND DEREK.
MS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ELENA HOUSLEY.
EIGHTEEN GREW UP IN NAPA AND WAS
A STUDENT AT PEPPERDINE
UNIVERSITY.
CHOOSE A GRADUATE OF VINTAGE
HIGH SCHOOL WITH A FOUR POINT
FIVE GRADE POINT AVERAGE IN A
STUDENT LEADER AND DEDICATED
ATHLETE.
WHOSE LOVE FOR MUSIC WAS
CONSTANT IN HER YOUNG LIFE.
ELENA WAS THE REGENTS
SCHOLARSHIP PEPPER NINE RECENTLY
ACCEPTED TO STUDY ABROAD PROGRAM
AND ON TO THE UNIVERSITY'S MOCK
TRIAL TEAM.
A LINE ELAINE IS SURVIVED BY HER
LOVING PARENTS ERIC IN HANNAH.
HER BROTHER ALEX.
AND HER DEVOTED GRANDPARENTS
AUNTS UNCLES AND COUSINS.
HIS -- WHEN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED DAM AND RE
GAY A RESIDENT OF THOUSAND OAKS
WAS THIRTY THREE YEARS OLD?
HE WAS A MARINE CORPS VETERAN
WHO SERVED IN THE MIDDLE EAST
WITH THE TWENTY SIXTH MARINE
EXPEDITIONARY UNIT.
DAN WAS OF PACIFIC REGION
PROGRAM MANAGER AT THE VETERANS
NONPROFIT TEAM RED WHITE AND
BLUE.
WORKING TO IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
VETERANS AND NEEDS.
DAN TO SURVIVE BY HIS FATHER
MARIO MOTHER ELSA SISTERS GLADYS
AND GLADYS AND GABRIELLE A
BROTHER MARCOS AS WELL AS HIS
GRANDMOTHER NIECE AND NEPHEW.
MANY AUNTS UNCLES AND COUSINS.
JUSTIN MEEK WAS.
TWENTY THREE LIVED IN NEWBURY
PARK.
HE WAS A RECENT GRADUATE OF CAL
LUTHERAN UNIVERSITY WHO MAJORED
IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
AND WORKED IN THE VETERANS
RESOURCE CENTER.
HE WAS AN EMPLOYEE OF BORDERLINE
WITH CHANNEL ISLAND SOCIAL
SERVICES.
PROVIDING RESPITE CARE TO
SPECIAL NEEDS FAMILIES.
AUSTIN WAS A LEADER AND
CONNECTOR WHO LOVED MUSIC.
HE WAS PLANNING TO JOIN THE US
COAST GUARD.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS FATHER
ROGER.
MOTHER LARA LYNN AND SISTER
VICTORIA ROSE MAKE.
TELEMARKETERS ARE FINE AS A
NATIVE OF THOUSAND OAKS WAS
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS OLD.
HEARING THE PRESTIGIOUS RANK OF
EAGLE SCOUT A TESTAMENT TO HIS
WORK ETHIC AND COMMITMENT TO
SERVING OTHERS.
WAS A NAVY VETERAN WHO SERVICE
AS A SONAR TECHNICIAN SURFACE
SEE MEN EARNED HIM THE NATIONAL
DEFENSE SERVICE MEDAL ANOTHER
AWARDS.
HE WAS A NATURAL LEADER WHO
INSPIRED OTHERS AROUND AND TELL
IS SURVIVED BY HIS PARENTS SUSAN
AND MARK AND BROTHER T!I.
NO WELL SPARKS WAS.
TWENTY ONE GREW UP IN THOUSAND
OAKS.
SHE WAS TO COLLEGE AND USE
LEADER AT CALVARY COMMUNITY
CHURCH.
WHERE SHE DID CONTRIBUTED TO THE
CHARACTER AND FACE DEVELOPMENT
OF COUNTLESS YOUNG PEOPLE?
WELL WAS A YOUNG ARTIST KNOWN
FOR HER WARMTH AND ABILITY TO
BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER ESPECIALLY
TO WORSHIP AND LINE DANCE.
SHE IS SURVIVED BY HER PARENTS
WINDY CRAWFORD ANDERSON AND TONY
SPARKS.
AND MANY OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS
AND FRIENDS.
VENTURA COUNTY SERGEANT.
CRISTINA MORISSETTE.
TWENTY WAS A RESIDENT OF SEAMY
VALLEY AND AN EMPLOYEE AT
BORDERLINE.
A GRADUATE OF SEAMY VALLEY HIGH
SCHOOL CRISTINA WAS A SUCCESSFUL
STUDENT AND AN ACCOMPLISHED
ATHLETE WHO IS BRIMMING WITH
TALENT.
INSPIRING HER PEERS THROUGH HER
HARD WORK IN HER COMMITMENT TO
REPRESENTING HER COMMUNITY AS A
JOURNALIST AND A CHEERLEADER.
SHE LOVED COUNTRY MUSIC AND
DANCING AND TOOK ON THE WORLD
WITH A FIERCE INDEPENDENCE.
CRISTINA IS SURVIVED BY HER
PARENTS MARTHA AND MICHAEL HER
BROTHER JASON AND HER SISTER
ALISON.
MS ARE.
ONE CENTER COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPUTY RON HILLIS RAN TOWARD
DANGER OF BORDERLINE ON NOVEMBER
SEVENTH.
PROVIDING THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
OTHERS TO FLEE TO SAFETY.
HE WAS FIFTY FOUR YEARS OLD.
A RESIDENT OF MORE PARK.
SERGEANT HILLIS WAS CLOSE TO
RETIREMENT AFTER TWENTY NINE
YEAR CAREER OF PUBLIC SERVICE.
WE'RE IS DEDICATION AND WORK
ETHIC WERE WELL KNOWN HE WAS A
MENTOR COACH AND POSITIVE
INFLUENCE ON HUNDREDS OF
DEPUTIES.
HERE THE MASTER'S DEGREE IN
TWENTY NINETEEN AND
ADMINISTRATIVE LEADERSHIP.
AND PLAN TO PURSUE A DOCTORATE
IN RETIREMENT HIS A LIFE
REFLECTED A LONG HISTORY OF
GOING ABOVE AND BEYOND FOR THE
PEOPLE AROUND THEM.
ON THE JOB.
WITH FAMILY AN AVID OUTDOORSMAN
INCLUDING FLY FISHING IN THE
SIERRA NEVADA WITH HIS SON
JORDAN.
RON HILLIS IS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE KAREN SON JORDAN AND MANY
MANY OTHER LOVING FAMILY MEMBERS.
WE'RE THANKFUL FOR ALL THE
HEROES THAT NIGHT INCLUDING MANY
INSIDE BORDER LINE WHERE THE
SHOOTING OCCURRED.
WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE HEROIC
EFFORTS OF OUR FIRST RESPONDERS
THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITY.
WHO RUSHED TO THE SCENE AS SOON
AS THE FIRST SHOTS WERE FIRED?
WHETHER THEY WERE ON DUTY OR NOT.
THE SELFLESS ACTIONS OF THE
SHERIFF'S DEPUTIES AND THE
OFFICERS FROM MANY SURROUNDING
AGENCIES NO DOUBT SAVE MANY
LIVES.
WE DRAWSTRING FROM THOSE WHO
BRAVELY STEPPED UP [inaudible]
THEIR COURAGE.
SERVICE AND SACRIFICE FOR THE
SAFETY OF OTHERS.
SUSTAINS US AND GIVES US HOPE.
AS WE HAVE HEARD THE STORIES
ABOUT THE LIVES OF THOSE WHO
WERE THERE THAT NIGHT WE HAVE
LEARNED HOW OUR PATHS CROSSED
HOW WE KNEW THE SAME PEOPLE.
OUR KIDS WENT TO THE SAME
SCHOOLS HOW THEY PLAYED SPORTS
TOGETHER.
OUR SIMILARITIES ARE GREATER
THAN OUR DIFFERENCES.
WE HAVE ALSO LEARNED THAT THERE
IS A COMMON THREAD THAT BINDS
OUR COMMUNITY TOGETHER AND HELPS
US SUPPORT GRIEVING FAMILIES AND
EACH OTHER.
THE TRAGEDY A BORDERLINE WAS
COMPOUNDED BY THE HILL AND WILL
THE FIRES THAT STARTED SOME
TWELVE HOURS LATER.
SOME VICTIMS FAMILIES SURVIVORS
AND DEPUTIES HAD TO EVACUATE
THEIR HOMES.
BUT REGARDLESS THE COMMUNITY
PULLED TOGETHER PEOPLE WAITED IN
LONG LINES TO DONATE BLOOD.
EVENTS WERE HELD AND CONTINUE TO
BE HELD TO SUPPORT VICTIMS
FAMILIES AND SURVIVORS.
THE SHERIFF AND THE POLICE CHIEF
HAVE ASSIGNED ADVOCATES TO
SUPPORT EACH FAMILY AND
THEMSELVES HAVE CONTINUE TO TALK
TO EACH AND EVERYONE OF THE
FAMILIES.
NOTHING WILL EASE THE PAIN
CAUSED BY THIS SENSELESS
VIOLENCE BUT WE MUST DO ALL WE
CAN TO EASE THEIR BURDEN.
WE ARE STRONGER TOGETHER AND
TOGETHER WE LIVE ON WITH THE
MEMORIES OF THOSE WE LOVED.
AND THOSE WHOSE LIVES WERE
TOUCHED.
TOGETHER WE CAN TAKE SOLACE.
IN THE BOUNDS OF COMMUNITY.
MEMORY AND HOPE THAT SUSTAIN US
IN OUR SORROW.
WE ARE COMMITTED. TO ENSURING
THAT THE LIVES OF KODY
[inaudible]
ELENA [inaudible]
BLAKE [inaudible]
DANIEL [inaudible]
JAKE [inaudible]
JUSTIN [inaudible]
CRISTINA WORK [inaudible]
NO WELL [inaudible]
SEAN.
TELEMARKETERS AND SERGEANT
HILLIS WILL NEVER BE FORGOTTEN.
THEY WILL LIVE ON IN OUR HEARTS
FOREVER.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
JOIN US IN A JOURNEYING IN THEIR
MEMORY.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE.
PEOPLE THAT ARE ON THE FLOOR
WITH US TODAY.
SERGEANT HE'LL AS HIS WIFE AND
SON JORDAN.
DAN MARIE CASE PERRANCE ELSA AND
MARIO.
CODY GIFFORDS PERRANCE JASON AND
CHERYL GIFFORD TATE.
JUSTIN MAKES MOTHER LARA LYNN
MEEK AND SISTER VICTORIA ROSE.
LANE IS HOUSE LEASE PARENTS ERIC
AND HANNAH.
NO WELL SPARKS MOTHER WENDY
ANDERSON.
MARK MAYES AS PERRANCE MARK
SENIOR AND KELLY MARSH.
BLAKE DEMONS PERRANCE LAURIE AND
DOWN.
SEAN ADLER'S WIFE FRAN.
CRISTINA MORISSETTE'S PERRANCE
MIKE [inaudible]
AND MARTHA.
I ALSO LIKE TO RECOGNIZE VENTURA
COUNTY SHERIFF BILL A. YOU HAD
RETIRED SHERIFF JEFF DEAN.
THOUSAND OAKS POLICE CHIEF TIM
HAGEL.
DEPUTY CRAIG WEB SENIOR DEPUTY
VIRGINIA SNAKE UP TO NOW GO.
AND CAPTAIN BILL SHARMAN.
REPRESENTING THE OFFICERS
RESPONDED TO THE BORDERLINE
SHOOTING.
AND IN THE GALLERY WE WELCOME
FAMILY MEMBERS FRIENDS.
AND THE ADVOCATES OF THOSE WE
HONOR TODAY.
THANK YOU MR WHEN.
I WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE THE
PRESENCE OF SENATORS HAD WE
STERN AS WELL AS SENATOR BILL
DODD ON THE FLOOR TO OBSERVE
THIS GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS ARE THERE ADDITIONAL
INTRODUCTIONS RELATIVE TO THIS A
GERMAN A MEMORY.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
MEMBERS AND GUESTS PLEASE RISE.
AS WE OBSERVE.
A MOMENT OF SILENCE.
AS WE REMEMBER.
AND HONOR THESE VICTIMS
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS
THANK YOU MEMBERS WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL GAS IN THE CHAMBER
TODAY.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL GAS
IN THE CHAMBER I LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY WOMAN GARCIA
FOR HER GUEST INTRODUCTION
ASSEMBLY WOMAN GARCIA.
THANK YOU IT'S WITH GREAT PRIDE
THAT TODAY I GET TO INTRODUCE
OUR BEATLES COLLEGE TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY.
RECOGNITION OF THEIR SUCCESSFUL
COLLEGE PROMISE PROGRAM. TO READ
OF COMPLETE WHICH ALSO WON THE
TWO THOUSAND X. I. EIGHTEEN
EXAMPLES OF EXCELLENCE AWARD.
EXAMPLES OF EXCELENCIA IS THE
ONLY NATIONAL EFFORT TO IDENTIFY
AND PROMOTE EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES THAT HELP ACCELERATE
LATINO STUDENT SUCCESS AND
HIGHER EDUCATION.
SO WITH THAT'S COMPLETE WAS
OFFICIALLY ESTABLISHED AT THE
COLLEGES CALIFORNIA PROMISE
PROGRAM IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
AND HAVE SERVED OVER FIFTEEN
HUNDRED STUDENT PARTICIPANTS.
THE COLLEGES LOCAL HIGH SCHOOLS.
SINCE THAT THE SECTION THE
COLLEGE HAS SEEN AT 30% INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF DEGREE AND
CERTIFIED CERTIFICATES AWARDED.
THREE ASSEMBLY PROVIDES LOCAL
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS WITH THE
MERIT BASED SCHOLARSHIP THAT
COVERS TUITION FREE FOR ONE YEAR.
THE PROMISED PROGRAM GIVE
STUDENTS PERSONALIZED ONE ON ONE
SUPPORT TO HELP THEM GRADUATE IN
LESS TIME.
WHEN 70% OF THIS IS A REAL
COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE LATINO AND
MOST OF THE STUDENTS ARE FIRST
GENERATION MANY OF THEM FROM MY
DISTRICT?
PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS GENERALLY
ARE PERFORM NON PARTICIPANTS IN
UNITS COMPLETED PERSISTENCE AND
COMPLETION OF ENTRY LEVEL MATH
AND ENGLISH AMONG OTHER AREAS.
CBS COMPLETE WAS ALSO NAMED AS A
FINALIST FOR THE RENOWN
BELLWETHER AWARD IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AS WE'RE
LOOKING TO MAKE SURE OUR
STUDENTS.
ARE GRADUATING A TIME THAT MAKES
SENSE HOW ENCOURAGE EVERYONE TO
LOOK AT WHAT'S REALLY DOES IS
DOING AS AN EXAMPLE FOR THE
WHOLE STATE OF HOW TO HELP ALL
OF OUR STUDENTS OUT THERE.
TODAY IN THE GALLERY PLEASE HELP
ME RECOGNIZE THEIR READERS
COLLEGE RESIDENTS TO BRING TEN
AND DR --
SET ALL EURO.
ADDRESS THE MEMBER START LUIS.
DID INTEREST DEVELOP ERA AND
DIRECTOR OF COLLEGE RELATIONS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS AND GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS MY A WALKER.
FINALLY ON BEHALF OF MYSELF AND
SPEAKER RENDON WHO'S A PROUD --
ALUMNI FROM THREE THOSE COLLEGE
THANK YOU FOR EXCELLING AT
EDUCATING THE NEXT GENERATION OF
CALIFORNIANS WORKFORCE AND
LEADERS.
AND CONGRATULATIONS ON A JOB
WELL DONE GOAL FALCONS.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN QUIRK SILVA YOU
HAVE GUESTS IN THE GALLERY TODAY
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER A
MEMBERS IT'S MY GREAT PLEASURE
TO WELCOME TODAY MEMBERS OF
NORTH ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT.
COLLEGE DID NO DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT HAS ESTABLISHED A
DISTRICT WIDE LEADERSHIP ACADEMY
PROGRAM. TO DEVELOP OUR
EMPLOYEES POTENTIAL IN ORDER TO
POSITIVELY A FLAT FACT STUDENT
SUCCESS AN INSTITUTIONAL
TRANSFORMATION.
THE LEADERSHIP ACADEMY FALLS
FOSTERS A MULTI DIMENSIONAL
PERSPECTIVE OF LEADERSHIP FROM
DEVELOPING INDIVIDUAL STRATEGIES
TO ENGAGING AND BROADER ADVOCACY.
THAT PREPARES PARTICIPANTS TO
BECOME INNOVATIVE CHANGE AGENTS
WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM.
NORTH ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT RESPECTS THE
EXISTING STRENGTHS AND EXPERTISE
THAT ALL OF IT SINCE EMPLOYEES
BRING TO THIS DISTRICT MEANING
THAT WHETHER YOU'RE A PROFESSOR
WHETHER YOU'RE WORKING IN THE
STUDENT STORE.
WHETHER YOU ARE WORKING IN A
STUDENT LAB EVERYBODY IS PART OF
THE TEAM. ONE OF THE CAT IS
ACADEMIES OBJECTIVES IS TO
EXPOSE PARTICIPANTS TO HOW
ADVOCACY WORKS WHICH IS WHY WE
HAVE THEIR DELEGATION JOINING US
TODAY MEMBERS OF NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT.
UNDERSTAND AND COMMIT TO AN
ADVOCATE FOR THE MISSION VISION
AND GOALS OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE MEMBERS PLEASE HELP ME
IN WELCOMING THIS GROUP.
OF LEADERS RIGHT UP HERE
[inaudible]
MR SANTIAGO.
I BELIEVE YOU HAVE GUESTS WHO
ARRIVED MISTER SANTIAGO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS --
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
STUDENT LEADERS FROM LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT HER
HERE ON THE ANNUAL.
LEGISLATIVE DAY WERE UP ON THE
GALLERY UP ON THE DOLLAR WE HAVE
JAMES INGRAM FROM LA CITY
COLLEGE.
BATTERIES ESPINO SO FROM LA
MISSION COLLEGE.
SERRANO JAKE UPS WITH LA
SOUTHWEST COLLEGE AND LA CCD
STUDENT TRUSTEE KELLY WILLIAMS.
I WELCOME TO THE CAPITAL.
THANK YOU MEMBERS
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
IS ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE PASS TO
RETAIN. ONE ITEM WE'RE GOING TO
BE TAKING UP FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWO THIS IS H. R..
SEVEN BY MS RAMOS RECOVERY.
HOUSE RESOLUTION SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AWARENESS MONTH.
RAISE YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT.
H. R. SEVEN WHICH PROCLAIMS
JANUARY TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AS
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AWARENESS
MONTH.
CALIFORNIA HAS ONE OF THE
HIGHEST INCIDENCES OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IN THE NATION.
IT IS THE TOP DESTINATION FOR
TRAFFICKERSBECAUSE OF ITS MAJOR
HARBORS [inaudible]
AIRPORTS COASTLINES
INTERNATIONAL BORDERS ECONOMY
AND IMMIGRANT POPULATION.
ACCORDING TO THE INTERNATIONAL
LABOR ORGANIZATION.
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT THERE ARE
FORTY POINT THREE MILLION
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
GLOBALLY.
OF THOSE 80% OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS ARE TRAPPED
IN FORCED LABOR. 25% BEING
CHILDREN AND 75% ARE WOMEN AND
GIRLS.
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL HUMAN
TRAFFICKING HOTLINE SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN IN CALIFORNIA
ALONE THERE BEEN OVER SEVEN
THOUSAND CASES REPORTED WITH
OVER TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND PHONE
CALLS TO THE HOT LINE.
WERE DISPROPORTIONATELY WOMEN AT
THE MINERS ARE AFFECTED.
THE STATISTICS ARE FRIGHTENING.
POPE FRANCIS ONCE SAID.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS A SCORED
CHURCH A CRIME AGAINST THE WHOLE
OF HUMANITY.
IT IS TIME TO JOIN FORCES AND
WORK TOGETHER TO FREE ITS
VICTIMS AND TO RATHER QUE TO
THIS CRIME.
AS IT AFFECTS ALL OF US FROM
INDIVIDUAL FAMILIES TO THE
WORLDWIDE COMMUNITY.
THE LEGISLATURE MUST RECOGNIZE
IS A GOOD SIGNIFICANT MORAL.
AND ECONOMIC HARM OF FORCED
LABOR AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING. TO
BOTH THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE CITIZENS ACROSS THE GLOBE.
TOGETHER WE CAN ADDRESS ADDRESS
THIS CRITICAL ISSUE.
SORRY SPECTRALLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
NAME ADDRESS MISTER GRAYSON.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE
RESOLUTION.
I RISE TODAY TO SUPPORT HR SEVEN
AND THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
BERNADINO FOR BRINGING FORTH
THIS PROFOUNDLY IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION.
FIRST I THINK MY ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES TO JOIN ME IN
SECURING MUCH NEEDED FUNDING AND
IN THE CURRENT BUDGET FOR FAMILY
JUSTICE CENTERS THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE. FOR THOSE THAT MIGHT NOT
KNOW FAMILY JUSTICE CENTERS ARE
COMPREHENSIVE MULTI AGENCY
CENTERS THE PROVIDE A ONE STOP
SHOP.
OF SUPPORT SERVICES TO VICTIMS
OF INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE
INCLUDING HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
EVERY DAY AFTER A SEIZE ARE
WORKING ON THE FOR AND HE'LL
VICTIMS AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE
ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES TO VISIT
AND AFTER YOU SEE IN THEIR
COMMUNITY. TO SEE THE LIFE
CHANGING WORK THAT THEY DO AGAIN
I THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
BERNADINO FOR OFFERING THIS
RESOLUTION AND PROVIDING AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US ALL TO
RECOMMIT OURSELVES. TO ENDING
HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
THING RESTORATION.
MISS WALDRON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ARE RISE AS JOIN AUTHOR
OF HR SEVEN WHICH IS A
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
RESOLUTION.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AFFECTS PEOPLE
OF ALL AGES AND IS A SCOURGE TO
OUR SOCIETY.
THIS MODERN FORM OF FLAYED
SLAVERY IS HAPPENING ALL AROUND
US AND CALIFORNIA MUST TAKE AN
ACTIVE STANCE OF PREVENTING AND
ELIMINATING HUMAN TRAFFICKING
ONCE AND FOR ALL.
THE STATISTICS ARE
UNCONSCIONABLE FORCED LABOR AND
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY BILLION DOLLAR A YEAR
INDUSTRY WORLDWIDE.
MORE THAN FORTY MILLION VICTIMS
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING GLOBALLY
AND 81% OF THOSE VICTIMS ARE
TRAPPED IN FORCED LABOR. 25% ARE
CHILDREN AND 75% ARE WOMEN AND
GIRLS AND IT SADDENS ME TO SAY.
THE CALIFORNIA HAS ONE OF THE
HIGHEST INCIDENCES OF YOU MEN
TRAFFICKING IN THE NATION.
CALIFORNIA IS A TOP DESTINATION
FOR TRAFFICKERS BECAUSE OF ITS
MAJOR HARBOURS AIRPORTS
COASTLINES INTERNATIONAL BORDERS
AND ECONOMY.
THE FBI LIST CALIFORNIA AND
NEVADA AS HAVING THE HIGHEST
RATE OF CHILD PROSTITUTION IN
THE WESTERN UNITED STATES.
CALIFORNIA IS BETTER THAN THAT
WE MUST REMAIN AWARE AND
VIGILANT TO PROTECT THE VICTIMS
OF THIS HORRIFIC CRIME.
WE MUST STAND AGAINST HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND COMMIT TO
PROVIDING ADEQUATE RESOURCES TO
PREVENT IT AND SERVICES TO HELP
VICTIMS AND SO ON BEHALF OF THE
VICTIMS.
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR HR
SEVEN IT'S JANUARY TWENTY
NINETEEN AS HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AWARENESS MONTH.
THERE WAS WALDRON MIS READ US
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY SUPPORT TO SUPPORT HR
SEVEN IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY ALONE.
POLICE OFFICERS MADE NINE ARREST
FOR HUMAN TRAFFICKING TWENTY
FIVE ARREST FOR PIMPING AND
PANDERING AND ARRESTED SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE JOHNS.
IN CALIFORNIA WHERE WE VALUE
EACH LIFE THESE NUMBERS ARE
UNACCEPTABLE.
I AM GRATEFUL FOR THE WORK OF
OUR LA POLICE DEPARTMENTS HUMAN
TRAFFICKING TASK FORCE.
ON LA CITY COUNCILMAN MARIE
MARTINEZ AND THE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THEY'RE FIGHTING
AGAINST HUMAN TRAFFICKERS AND
FOR PROVIDING SERVICES TO THE
VICTIMS IN MY DISTRICT.
IT'S APPARENT THAT WE WANT TO
END HUMAN TAP TRAFFICKING WE
ONLY TO BE IN IT TOGETHER.
THIS IS WHY I STAND IN SUPPORT
AND COMMEND MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN BERNARDINO FOR AUTHORING HR
SEVEN TO RECOGNIZE JANUARY AS
HUMAN TRAFFICKING PREVENTION
MONTH THANK YOU.
VETERANS RIVERS MISS RUBIO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION.
MARKING JANUARY AS HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AWARENESS MONTH.
THE JEWISH COMMUNITY KNOWS FAR
TOO WELL THE HORRORS OF BEING
TAKEN FROM HOME AND FAMILY.
ONLY TO BE AT THE WILL OF YOUR
TORMENTORS AND CAPTORS.
AND WE ARE COMMANDED TO USE THE
BLESSINGS OF OUR FREEDOM TO
ENSURE THAT OTHERS ARE KEPT SAFE
AND SECURE.
THE NUMBER OF INNOCENT SOULS WHO
ARE TRAFFICKED IN OUR STATE IS
ALARMING THE STORIES OF THE
INNOCENT CHILDREN.
WHO ARE ASSAULTED AND SOLD OVER
AGAIN IS HEART BREAKING?
BY TAKING THE STAND WE COMMIT
OURSELVES AS LEADERS OF THIS
GREAT STATE. TO NOT STAND IDLY
BY AND ALLOW THESE ATROCITIES TO
CONTINUE [inaudible]
JUST YESTERDAY.
WE AS A JEWISH COMMUNITY
COMMEMORATED INTERNATIONAL
HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE DAY.
TOGETHER WE REMEMBERED THE
ATROCITIES OF THE SIX MILLION
KILLED.
AND VOWED THE IMMORTAL WORDS
NEVER AGAIN.
THESE WORDS NEVER AGAIN GUIDE
OUR PURSUIT OF JUSTICE FOR ALL
PEOPLE [inaudible]
NEVER AGAIN.
MEANS WE WILL FIGHT TO END
GENOCIDE WE WILL FIGHT TO END
SLAVERY AND WE WILL FIGHT TO AND
TRAFFICKING TO ENSURE THAT ALL
CHILDREN RECEIVE THE BLESSINGS.
OF LIFE.
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MS RUBIO MR HOLDEN
THEIR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION HR.
SEVEN RESOLUTION TO BRING
AWARENESS OF HUMAN TRAFFIC AND I
THINK THE MEMBER FROM SEPTEMBER
TO DO YOU KNOW FOR HER.
CONTINUE LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS A FORM OF
MODERN DAY SLAVERY AND CONTINUES
TO HAPPEN IN OUR STATE.
AT AN ALARMING RATE.
IT IS CURRENTLY ESTIMATED THAT
THERE ARE FORTY POINT THREE
MILLION VICTIMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING GLOBALLY.
BUT ISN'T IT IS NOT JUST A
GLOBAL ISSUE.
AND TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
CALIFORNIA WAS ONE OF THREE
STATES THAT RECEIVED THE HIGHEST
NUMBERS.
OF REPORTED CLOUT CASES OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
AND TRAGICALLY THIS REALITY IS
EVEN WORSE IN THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
ACCORDING TO THE BUREAU OF
JUSTICE STATISTICS.
WERE REYES WAS KNOWN SEX
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS WERE 40%
MORE LIKELY TO BE AFRICAN
AMERICAN.
MY EXPERIENCE CARRIED AB FIFTEEN
A BILL THAT GAVE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS MORE TIME TO
FILE HUMAN RIGHTS CLAIM.
SHOWED ME AND HOPEFULLY OTHERS
HOW EASILY ONE CAN GET TRAPPED.
HOW DIFFICULT IT IS TO GET FREE
AND THE CHALLENGES TO GET
JUSTICE?
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE.
IT FIRST STARTS WITH US WITH US
BECOMING MORE AWARE IN SPREADING
THAT AWARENESS IN OUR DISTRICTS.
I LOOK FORWARD TO MORE
LEGISLATION THE COMING YEARS
THAT BETTER IDENTIFIES WAYS TO
BETTER PROSECUTE.
THESE CRIMES AND PROVIDE VICTIMS
WITH THE RESOURCES FOR RECOVERY.
I AM THROUGH THE ASSET COOLEY
ASK FOR YOUR STRONG SUPPORT.
OF HR SO.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN SEEING
NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE RESOLUTION.
MS RACE YOU MAY CLOSE.
I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR COMMENTS
TODAY.
I THINK IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE
SHED LIGHT ON THE SOCIETY
SOCIETAL ISSUE OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ANNOUNCED THAT THE FIRST
ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS
MEMBERS THE FIRST ROLE WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON HR SEVEN
CORPORAL OF IN THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE THERE SIXTY SEVEN CO
AUTHORS ADDED AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THIS HOUSE RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THAT RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
AND MR FONG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GUESTS INTRODUCTION
RELATIVE TO THIS HOUSE
RESOLUTION.
THIS FALL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
TODAY I RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR
SEVEN AND TO RECOGNIZE AN
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS TO FIGHT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IN THE CENTER
VALLEY EVERYDAY.
THE FRESNO ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES COMMISSIONS
CENTRAL VALLEY AGAINST HUMAN
TRAFFICKING PROGRAM HELPS LEAD
THE ANTI TRAFFICKING EFFORTS
THROUGHOUT THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
THE EEOC PARTNERS WITH NON
PROFITS IN MERCED MADERA FRESNO
TULARE KINGS IN CURRENT COUNTIES
WORKING TO HELP SURVIVORS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING REBUILD THEIR
LIVES.
THE OC PROGRAMS PROVIDE EVER
EMERGENCY SHELTER TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING CASE MANAGEMENT AND
TRANSPORTATION TO VICTIMS OF ALL
FORMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
THEY CONSISTENTLY REPRESENT THE
REGION IN THE STATE AND NATION
WIDE IN THEIR ANTI TRAFFICKING
EFFORTS AS WELL.
FRESNO'S EOC CEO BRIAN AG AND
GUESTS AS WELL AS ELIZABETH
JONASSON STRATEGY AND
COMMUNICATIONS OFFICER FOR THE
OC I HEAR IN THE GALLERY TODAY.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING
BRIAN ELIZABETH FOR THEIR HARD
WORK IN THEIR EFFORTS TO END
HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
THANK YOU MEMBERS MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS MEMBERS YESTERDAY
WAS ASSEMBLY WOMAN RACES
BIRTHDAY.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WISHING HER A
HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
AND THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN INVITES
ALL OF YOU TO JOIN HER FOR CAKE
IN HER OFFICE SWITCHES ROOM
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY FIVE UPON A
GERMAN.
OF SESSION THE SESSION SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY JANUARY
TWENTY NINTH CHECK IN SESSION.
WEDNESDAY JANUARY THIRTIETH
CHECK IN SESSION.
THURSDAY.
JANUARY THIRTY FIRST FLOOR
SESSION IS A NINE A ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED TO
RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED.
SEEING HARRY NO FURTHER BUSINESS
I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN [inaudible]
MISTER.
MS RUBIO MOVES AND MISTER FLORA
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY JANUARY
THIRTY FIRST AT NINE AM AND A
QUORUM CALLS LIFTED